- How about the first
time we actually met?
I hope you remember.
- I do.
I literally say like, do you
know, do you remember meeting?
I was like, absolutely.
It was in a hallway.
It was so random.
It was with clay Aiken
and we just sat down in a hallway.
Were you locked out?
Someone was locked up
or something happened.
There was a reason why
we were in the hallway.
- Yeah. Yes.
I had forgotten that morning.
We were doing Celebrity Apprentice.
It was down to me and Clay Aiken.
and I'd forgotten, that morning,
to put the little card on the door
So the housekeeper would know to come in.
So I get home and my room is a wreck
the way I left it at 7:00 AM.
So I told Clay,
I'm just going to sit here
while she does my room.
And God works in mysterious ways.
The elevator door opens.
Clay Aiken and I are sitting
on the floor of Trump Tower.
And you walk out of the elevator
and you were clean as the Board of Health.
I don't know who dressed you
that day, but it was nuts.
And I say that only to
say you did something
that made me love you forever.
- What?
- You put your purse down and
you sat on the floor with us.
- Yeah!
- We talked for like an hour and a half,
and that was the best way
to meet one of my favorite singers,
who actually reminds me a lot of Aretha.
- You better stop it right
now, sir, I will cry.
I'm emotional this week.